-I'm here with my co-host Megan Thee Stallion.
Her album "Traumazine" -- -Yeah!
-"Traumazine" is out at midnight tonight.
Put it on loop on Spotify and have it go all night long.
-Everything. Just over and over.
-I want to try something fun with you.
So I think it's time for "Mad Lib Hip Hop Karaoke."
Here we go. -Okay.
-♪ Oh, it's Mad Lib Karaoke ♪
♪ Ohh, Mad Lib Karaoke ♪
-So, here's how this works.
We're gonna take turns singing hip-hop songs,
but we're gonna swap out some of the original lyrics
with brand-new words.
To do that, I'm gonna ask you for some suggestions --
some nouns, verbs, adjectives. -I'm scared.
Yeah. Good. Ready? -It's good that I'm scared?
-Oh, you said you're scared? -Yeah.
-No, don't be scared. -He's like, "Yeah, good."
-No, it's gonna be fun. -Okay.
-No, no. I thought you said -- -I'm ready.
-Yeah. Okay. Good. It's gonna be easy.
-Okay. -Occupation.
-A nurse. -Yep.
Three sports.
-Football.
Croquet. Croquet.
[ Laughter ]
-Judges? Judges? Can we use -- [ Ding ]
Yeah, they said we can use croquet.
Of course. -And soccer.
Yes!
-Three words that rhyme.
-Head, bed, lead. -Okay.
A question.
-Did you fart?
[ Laughter ]
-You're not actually -- Yeah. Here we go.
"Did you..." Alright. Okay.
An animal.
-A dog. -Oh.
-Or a zebra. -Zebra.
Zebra's good. Yep. Three types of beans.
-A Lima bean. -Yep.
-A pinto bean. -Pinto.
-And a -- a refried bean?
[ Laughter ]
-Refried bean is so funny. -Refried bean.
-That's so good. Alright. Three made-up words.
-Uh... -Oh.
-Yeah. Traumazine.
Pressurelicious.
-Hold on. Traumazine. -Mm-hmm.
Presh... -Pressure. Licious.
L-I-C-I-O-U-S.
[ Chuckles ] And body-ody. -Ah!
-Yes! -♪ Body-ody-ody-ody ♪
-Yes. -That's so good.
-We can do this. -Okay. Alright.
So here's what we're gonna do.
Now we're putting them into the cue cards over here.
We're going to give you this magic microphone.
-Check, check.
-And, Megan, since you're my guest,
you'll be singing first. You're gonna be singing
a Mad Lib version of...
"Savage" by Megan Thee Stallion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You ready for this?
-I can do this. [ Clears throat ]
I'm ready.
♪♪
♪ I'm a nurse ♪
♪ Football, croquet, soccer ♪
♪ Yeah, head, bed, lead ♪
♪ Yeah, acting stupid, did you fart? ♪
♪ Did you fart? ♪
♪ I'm a zebra, lima, pinto, refried ♪
♪ Traumazine, Pressurelicious, Body-ody ♪
♪ Acting stupid, did you fart? ♪
♪ Did you fart? ♪
-There you go! Come on, now.
How? How do you make it sound cool?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ] You know it. It's your song.
-Yes! Luckily. -Come on, buddy.
-I might be a rapper or something.
-You might be. Yeah. Might be the best. Yeah.
Alright. This last one here. Ready?
I'm just gonna give you -- We'll go super speed round.
-Okay. -Give me a number.
-Fo'.
-Last name. -Pete.
-Ooh.
-It's my last name. -It is.
-Store at the mall. -Forever 21.
[ Laughter ]
-McDonald's item.
-Uh, McFlurry.
-Ooh. -Yes.
-Fix the machine. -When the machine's working.
Fix the mach-- -Fix the machine!
[ Laughter ]
-"Fix the machine" is so funny.
[ Laughs ] Silly word.
-Booty.
-Yeah. Let's just do booty. -I think booty is silly.
-Booty is good. -It's a good word.
-It's silly, and it's a good word, yeah.
Instrument. -A trumpet.
-Trumpet.
A type of bird. -A crow.
-Ooh. A condiment.
-Ranch.
-[ Gasps ] Really? -Yes.
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm not a ranch person.
I know. The world hates me because I said that.
-You're not a ranch person?
I guarantee you half of the things you eat require ranch.
-No, I think that half of the things you eat
shouldn't have ranch on them.
[ Laughter ]
Right? -No! Salads.
-Are you -- Pizza crust?
-Pizza! -No!
-Who don't eat pizza with ranch?!
[ Laughter ]
Well, okay. What condiment do you like?
Mayonnaise.
-No! How do you think mayonnaise?
[ Laughter ]
You said it so fast.
No, actually, mayonnaise grosses me out.
-Okay. -Mustard.
-[ Laughs ] The most basic condiment.
Okay. Mustard. Come on. Let's do mustard.
-Another condiment. No, I can do ranch.
It actually says "another condiment."
Bingo! Mustard.
Oh, yeah. Do you do "rustard"? Mustard. "Rustard."
-Rustard. I do rustard. -You do?
-Yeah, on weekends. -What time of --
[ Laughter ]
Tell him I said hi. Will you? -Yes.
-Letter of the alphabet.
[ Laughter ]
Rustard.
-Rust...
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. -J.
-J. I love you. Two-syllable noun.
-Balloon. -Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Nice. Plural cute animal.
Dogs. -Yeah, dogs.
-Yes. -One-syllable sound.
-Boom! -Boom!
Another one-syllable sound.
-Pow. -Pow!
Love it.
-What is this song? -What is this one?
I don't know. I'm gonna find out, too.
Oh, it's a duet for us. -Yes! A duet. Oh, man.
-So, here's your mic. Here's my mic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are doing a duet of...
"Nuthin' but a 'G' Thang" by Dr. Dre and Snoop Dogg.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
♪♪
♪ One, two, three, and to the fo' ♪
-♪ Snoop Doggy Dogg and Dr. Pete is at Forever 21 ♪
-♪ Ready to make a McFlurry, so back on up ♪
-♪ 'Cause you know we're about to rip booty up ♪
-♪ Give me the trumpet, so I can bust down like a crow ♪
♪ Ranch and mustard together, you know we're in trouble ♪
-♪ It ain't nothin' but a J thang, balloon ♪
♪ Two loc'ed out dogs, so we're crazy ♪
♪ It's like boom and pow and boom and pow ♪
♪ It's like boom and pow, boom and pow ♪
-That's it right there. Megan Thee Stallion.
We're talking to Megan after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
♪ Boom, pow, boom, pow ♪
♪ Ranch and mustard and the ♪ -Yes!
-♪ Boom, pow, boom, pow ♪
♪ Ranch and mustard and a ♪